en camerún los estadios están listos
para acoger los partidos de lacan la
copa africana de naciones pero es
difícil saber si tanto el público como
los jugadores cumplirán con esta cita
porque para asistir al torneo la
confederación africana de fútbol ha
establecido un protocolo muy estricto el
aforo máximo se ha fijado en un 60 por
ciento para la mayoría de los partidos y
en un 80 para los encuentros de camerún
el anfitrión los espectadores deben
también presentar una prueba pcr
negativa con vigencia menor a 72 horas o
presentar prueba del esquema de
vacunación completo pero en camerún
solamente el 6 por ciento de los mayores
de 18 años están vacunados
muy poca gente se vacuna entonces hay un
riesgo de tener unos estadios con poco
ambiente por después si quiero someterme
a la prueba para ir al estadio pero
estoy en contra de la vacuna con fútbol
dado que soy amante del fútbol claro que
me voy a hacer vacunar para ir al
estadio estatal la confederación
africana de fútbol ya ha puesto en
guardia a camerún contra la
proliferación de pruebas pcr falsas por
parte de los futbolistas el co beat ya
deja a varios afectados en la selección
de senegal 3 jugado y tres miembros del
equipo técnico dieron positivo antes de
partir al territorio africano también se
detectaron contagios en las elecciones
de gambia y camerún
la estrella del arsenal el gabonés
pierre-emerick aubameyang fue puesto en
aislamiento a su llegada a camerún en
caso de que una prueba pcr confirme su
positivo si perdería el primer partido
de su combinado contra comoras el
próximo lunes